- All right, welcome, everybody,
to AWS detection and response innovations
that drive security outcomes.
My name is Marshall Jones,
I'm a security SA at AWS.
Day to day, I focus on our
detection and response services
that we'll talk about doing go-to market,
helping customers operationalize
and scale these services,
as well as get great
feedback from our customers
to drive kind of service
innovation going forward.
So let Ryan introduce himself.
- Sure, yeah.
I'm Ryan Holland and I lead
the GuardDuty service team.
- All right, so this is
a talk that has happened
at re:Inforce and re:Invent in the past,
where we go over all the new launches
and innovations in our
detection and response services.
So if you're returning
to this talk, welcome.
If you are new, also welcome.
What we're gonna cover
in this conversation
is an overview of our detection
and response portfolio.
What are these native services?
How do customers normally use them?
Or we're gonna go through a
number of different demos.
We're gonna talk about our
new features and capabilities.
We will also try and save
some time at the end.
If folks have questions or
want to connect afterwards,
we can do that as well, too.
So we're gonna get started
with kind of the problem space
that we see quite often.
Like I said, day to day,
talk to a lot of different customers
about the different security challenges
that they're trying to overcome
at their organizations.
And these ultimately get lumped
into a few different things.
Mainly, a lot of fragmented visibility.
Good security response, security
operations is usually built
on somewhat of a data
problem, unfortunately.
For some of the security
practitioners out there.
This is having visibility,
having the access to the data
that you need to have visibility
into what's going on in your environment,
what might be a risk,
what might be just a,
you know, an benign vulnerability
or something like that.
And really, understanding what
actually you have out there,
so you know what to make decisions on,
what to go respond to,
what to go remediate.
Some of these different
information that we get over time
has limited context across
the whole environment.
So kind of leading into our
different third challenge
as well too is being
disconnected security signal.
So either the signal
doesn't have much context
and we really need more
information to truly understand
what a different security
signal is telling us.
And then also not having
specific signals together.
So there's a lot of jumping
between different tooling
and a lot of, you know,
putting different pieces
of the puzzle that don't
really fit together to try
and understand of what
is in an overall picture.
And then ultimately, what that
causes is a delayed response.
Security is obviously one of those things
that folks just want to work,
so they can focus on their business.
And when there's delayed
response, delayed remediation,
that is, you know, obviously,
something that is a challenge
for security teams as
well as business owners,
and something nobody really wants, right?
So ultimately, what are
the things that we want
to accomplish based on these challenges
and based on like the business outcomes
that we want to drive with
these native detection
and response services.
So first, protecting your workloads
against security risk, right?
Pretty simple.
You have different workloads,
different applications on AWS,
different infrastructure
protection for those
is the utmost importance.
Centralizing, monitoring,
enhancing visibility
into potential risk.
So what we mean by that
is how do we do this
kind of in one place and not
in a bunch of different places
to make this easier for folks
to come to the conclusions that they need,
or the insights that they
need to derive from their data
and their security
tooling in a central spot.
Ultimately, we want to investigate
and respond to these
security issues quickly.
So going back to the challenge
with delayed responses,
how can we do this as quickly as possible
across the incident response
or security operations
kind of lifecycle, right?
All the way from a detection,
to an investigation,
to a response and a remediation.
And then we are, you know, quite aware
that customers are in multiple
different environments.
So how do we do this
across hybrid environments
and hybrid different applications,
and do this using AWS native services
in kind of a single place.
So if you're familiar with our detection
and response services, they really fit
into a few different categories.
So the first category
being threat detection
and workload protection.
This is where a number of
different things happen
really behind the GuardDuty service.
And Ryan's gonna jump
into what this looks like
and how people utilize
this in more detail.
But we're bringing a wealth
of knowledge across AWS,
across our different threat intel sources,
and signals from our large
customer base to understand
where threats might be happening
in a customer's environment,
utilizing this tool, or you
know, what are the new threats
and kind of ever evolving threats
that customers need to be looking out for,
and making this ultimately easy for them
to go do this at scale.
The second piece is
vulnerability management.
So we really see this in a
couple of different tools.
So if you're familiar with
Inspector or Security Hub CSPM,
we can see an automatic discovery
of misconfigurations of AWS resources.
Like for example, you've
got some EC2 instance
that doesn't have EBS volume encryption,
or you've got public SQS queues,
or this may be a specific vulnerabilities
that we'll see in packages
and operating systems.
They might be code vulnerabilities
in Lambda functions,
or it might be, you know,
vulnerability discovery
through CI/CD pipelines,
and this is some of the
detail that we'll jump into.
And then finally, risk management.
We have some great new information
to share with you all here,
but risk management is obviously something
that folks want to evaluate
across their environment.
So one of the things that we talk
to customers quite often
about is, you know,
how do I determine what I
should go prioritize first?
What is my biggest risk in my environment?
So what we wanna do as far
as the risk management pillar
and in Security Hub,
which we'll talk about
that was launched GA at
the keynote yesterday,
is to understand what is our risk posture
across our environment?
What should we go respond to first?
What is the context
across this environment
to understand why we should
prioritize that first,
and ultimately, you know,
to correlate this risk posture
across our environment.
So with that said, we'll
jump into the first service
and I'll let Ryan take over.
- Awesome, thanks, Marshall.
Yeah, so as Marshall mentioned,
our first service to talk
about is Amazon GuardDuty,
which if you're not familiar,
is our native threat detection service.
It's fully managed, it uses a variety
of different techniques in
order to identify threats
that could impact your
workloads, your identities,
including things on containers,
as well as RDS databases
and Lambda functions as well.
And one of the most important things
about the way that this
works is it is fully managed.
You don't have to feed
any of the data to us
for us to be able to process it.
We manage all of this on your
behalf behind the scenes,
and it helps customers
detect suspicious activity
or malicious activity.
And we have added a bunch of neat features
that really help analysts
get to the bottom
of what is going on that's
caused an alert to be created
with our extended threat detection,
which we'll talk about in detail,
that gives you a really deep
insight into the activity
that we're observing
within your environment.
We have some features
that we'll talk about
that can assist with preventing
or detecting the presence of ransomware.
And we centralize this across
your entire AWS estate.
So, you know, typically, most customers
don't have just one or two accounts.
You have a large number of AWS
accounts in most enterprises.
And so using the AWS
organization's integration,
we have a function called
delegated administrator,
which allows the organization admin
to delegate control of
the GuardDuty service
to a security-owned account.
And that security
operator then can control
and configure which
features they want enabled,
on which counts they
want those enabled on.
There's even the ability
to just configure it for auto-enable.
So if a new account is
created in the organization,
or if a new account gets added
to the organization later,
you don't have to go and keep track
and bootstrap that account any longer.
So with the organization's integration
and the auto-enablement feature,
we will just automatically
see there's a new account
that's added, and that you've
told us that all new accounts
should have this particular
security configuration,
we'll automatically apply that for you.
And we also see that the
threat detection here
helps customers satisfy
several different types
of compliance requirements
including PCI DSS.
So just wanna take a minute to
talk about how do we do this.
So the first part is getting
access to the data that we need
in order to identify potential threats.
And from a data perspective,
we break these into two categories.
The foundational data sources.
These are always on for all
customers that enable GuardDuty,
and these are flow logs, DNS
query logs, and CloudTrail.
Very important to point out,
you don't have to turn these on.
We get access to all of these
log sources behind the scenes,
directly through integrations
from the core service
teams that produce them.
This has a couple key benefits.
One is cost.
If you don't otherwise have a reason
that you would need to store
and actually get your flow logs,
you don't have to turn those on.
We still get to see them.
It also has some security
benefits as well,
because if a malicious
actor got, you know,
access to an account, they can't
go and disable a log source
and prevent us from getting
access to that data.
So in addition to those
foundational data sources,
we also have a host of,
we call protection plans.
These are add-ons that,
you know, you can enable,
either, again, across
the entire organization.
You can also pick and
choose individual accounts,
where you want them on.
One of the important things
I always like to point out
is each of these protection plans,
as well as the foundation data centers,
comes with a 30-day free trial.
So you can turn them on.
And if you have an
account that, for example,
isn't using EKS and you
turn on the EKS protection,
there's no charge for that being enabled
until an EKS cluster shows up.
So sometimes, we see
customers turn them on
even for services they're
not actively using.
And once we have all that data,
we look at it in several different ways.
So there's multiple different
ways we can detect threats.
In some of these threats, we
can detect, we call stateless.
We can look at a single event
and say, "This is not good."
Good example of this
would be threat intelligence-based
detections, right?
If you're querying a domain
that we know is bad, that's bad,
and we don't need to
see really anything else
in order to give you a finding for that.
And we get our threat intelligence
from several different places.
We partner with third parties.
So we partner with CrowdStrike
as well as Proofpoint.
So we collect that,
you don't need to have a license for that.
We apply that to the flows
and the DNS query requests
within your accounts.
We also generate a large amount
of threat intelligence internally
that we expose to customers
through GuardDuty.
So the Amazon act of defense
that runs our honeypots across the globe,
we get a lot of great threat
intelligence from them
that not only is it really good
quality threat intelligence,
but it's also very relevant
because this is threat intelligence
that is actually targeting our customers
because they're hitting our honeypots.
We also get threat intelligence
from our internal cert team,
which is looking at and trying
to protect Amazon as a whole.
And again, we externalize
all that by applying that
as threat intelligence to the workloads
for GuardDuty customers.
We also use several different
machine learning mechanisms
to detect behavioral anomalies.
And you'll see this
when we look at things,
like S3 access or EKS audit logs,
and as well as RDS logins,
where you can't just
look at a single event
and decide whether or
not it's good or bad.
We have to understand what is normal
for a particular user
or a particular bucket,
and then a build baselines and understand
whether or not the
activity that we're seeing
is generally consistent with
what we'd typically have
observed in the past.
And then in other cases, we
use some learning algorithms
that look for other types of baselines
that aren't really machine learning-based,
but still look at previous
behavioral activity
in order to look for deviations.
And then when we determine
that there's something
that warrants sending you a finding,
we first take that
information and we try to put
as much context into
these findings as we can.
So in addition to all of the data
that was in the source log
event that generated a finding,
we also expose additional context
that we can gather from our backend.
So for example, on the
machine learning findings,
we don't just tell you that
this user did something
that's unusual, we also
include all the information
that we have about what
we expected to see.
So what was the usual
activity that we observed
and then what was the
specific things that we saw
that were unusual in this particular case,
which can really usually help the kind
of first line responders look at
and determine whether or not it's,
you know, unusual but benign,
or unusual and worth
additional investigation.
We also add tags.
For resources that have tags,
we'll collect all the tag data, and again,
just trying to give as much context
and as much information as we can gather
about the resources that are impacted
and include those in the findings
to make them more actionable
because they have an additional context.
And all of these findings now also go
through our extended
threat detection analysis,
and I'll dive more into how
that works here in a minute.
And then all of our
findings, we, you know,
are obviously available in our console,
but we also send them out EventBridge.
So through the EventBridge integration,
you can send them to a
downstream seam or your SOC,
or other automated actions
that you might want to take.
We also send them to Security Hub,
which Marshall will show
you here in a little bit.
So they can be correlated
with other signals
that we see from within your accounts.
And you can also investigate
them with Detective
or send them through to
other partner tools as well.
So again, through the
EventBridge integration.
And then the last bit that we
have is our malware detection.
So from a malware perspective,
we allow customers to
scan their EBS volumes.
This is all done without any agents.
So there's no agents that
need to be installed,
no third party software to license.
And we do this in two different ways.
You can simply ask us to scan an instance
and we'll scan all the
volumes, but more generally,
what we see is customers
enable the scan on detection.
So we have gone through
the list of finding types
that we have in GuardDuty.
We've identified those
that are more relevant
for the presence of malware.
And so if we generate
one of those findings
behind the scenes, we'll
snapshot the volumes
for that instance, copy
them to a secure location,
and perform malware scan,
and then report back in
the presence of a finding.
And we'll also update the source finding
that created the need
for that scan as well.
We also offer malware scanning for S3.
So this was a feature that
a lot of our customers
were asking us for.
And it's really, especially right now,
targeting for the use
case of untrusted uploads.
So we have a lot of customers,
maybe you have a web app,
and your customers are sending you files
or uploading documents,
or maybe you're accepting
content from a third party.
And before you ingest that
into your application,
you wanna make sure
that there's no malicious
content in there.
So you can tell us which buckets
you need to have this protection on.
And anytime an object gets
placed in that bucket,
we'll immediately go and scan it,
and then we will tag it with the result.
So you can configure this in your pipeline
such that none of your
applications can access objects
that have identified as, you
know, having malicious content
to prevent that from getting
into your data pipelines.
If the file is cleaned, we'll
mark it as no threats found,
and then you can go ahead
and use that as a signal
to move it along through your application.
So I want to talk just a moment
about those different protection plans.
So again, these are all
the different expansions
that you can add, and
they add more context
and data into the
GuardDuty system as well,
which will become very
important in a minute
when we start to talk
about the extended
threat detection feature.
So S3 protection enables us
to take visibility into S3 data events.
So from a CloudTrail perspective
that's part of the
foundational data sources.
We see the management events
and that would include some S3 events,
like list buckets for example.
But it doesn't include the data events,
like get object, put
object, delete object.
So what is the actual activity
that a user is performing within a bucket?
With the SV protection turned on,
we get access to all of those logs.
And again, you don't have to turn
the data events on yourself,
we get 'em directly
from S3 on the backend.
And we use this to, again, build profiles
of normal activity for a bucket.
It's a particular bucket normally used
to as an input bucket, where
it's lots mostly rights.
We're suddenly seeing large
data being exfiltrated from it.
We also look at the principles
in which buckets they
tend to interface with
and how they do that actions
in order to identify
potentially anomalous behavior.
We also have our EKS protection.
So this gives us access
to the EKS audit logs.
And this is kind of similar
to your CloudTrail for EKS,
it's the control plane activity, you know,
what types of of pods are being created,
what types of activity is taking place
on that EKS controller itself.
Again, in order to
identify misconfigurations
like, you know, making
it publicly accessible
or also unusual activity, like suddenly,
we're seeing privileged containers
that we haven't seen in
your account previously.
That could be an indication
of an identity compromise.
We have our RDS protection.
So this looks at anomalous
behavior for logins
to database themselves.
So this is really on the
kind of the data plane
of the database and allow us
to profile what are the users,
what databases do they normally log in to,
where do they log in from,
other activity of that nature,
and to identify logins that
seem suspicious or unusual.
We have our Lambda protection,
which gives us visibility
into the network connections
for your Lambda functions.
So whether or not maybe you've downloaded
a third party library
that has been compromised,
and maybe your Lambda functions
are reaching out to command
and control or to crypto mine.
This'll give us visibility
into the flow log data
in order to identify
those malicious net flows.
And this works both for VPC-enabled
as well as non-VPC-enabled
Lambda functions.
So we'll get that visibility regardless
of the networking
configuration that you've used.
And then the last one is
our runtime monitoring.
So runtime monitoring
ads and EVPF-based agents
to your compute workload in order for us
to get even more context and visibility
into the activity that's taking place.
This is especially important
for containerized workloads, right?
Because if we're just
looking at the instance level
and you've got a hundred
pods on an instance,
knowing in the flow log
data isn't super helpful.
This will give us visibility
down to the process ID,
as well as all the lineage of the process
that was creating any flow
data or looking up any domains,
as well as executing processes.
And we support all of
our major compute types.
So we support Fargate,
we support ECS on EC2,
EKS as well as EC2
instances by themselves.
And we built this in a way
to make it fully managed
and really lightweight.
So again, it's EVPF-based.
So the agent itself, it
doesn't have any, you know,
kernel driver requirements.
But in order to make it
even more lightweight,
we designed this in such a fashion
that the runtime sensor itself
doesn't have really any
rules or logic built into it.
It's really collecting all this data
and it streams it to our
backend through a VPC endpoint.
And this allows us to
have a lot more expensive
and computationally expensive
rules and detection content
on the backend 'cause it's on our compute.
It also means that you never have to worry
about whether or not you
have an updated rule set
because all of those
rules are on our backend.
We can push an update
for an emergent threat,
and every single one of the millions
of agents out there automatically
have that protection.
So we're able to detect that very quickly.
And we can do this deployment
for you in a lot of cases.
So for EKS, we have a direct
integration on the back end
with the EKS service that allows us
to identify all EKS workloads
within your account.
And whenever there's a new
cluster that's created,
we'll create a managed add-on
that will add a Damon
set to all of your hosts,
and make sure that those
sensors are running.
For Fargate, again, your
developers don't need
to make any changes to their deployments.
If the GuardDuty Fargate
runtime is enabled,
when they submit a deployment
just as they would normally,
Fargate will see that the security admin
has chose to enable runtime,
and it will inject a sidecar
container into that deployment,
automatically making it very easy
and seamless for them
to get that protection.
For EC2 instances, we
leveraged systems manager
to affect those deployments as well.
And all of these also create
additional signal for,
which is one of our more recent launches,
which is extended threat detection.
So we originally launched
the extended threat detection
at this last re:Invent, looking
at two key data sources.
So the CloudTrail data source
and the S3 data source.
And we had two findings.
One was compromised credential,
one was compromised data,
so depending on which data source
was contributing more to the logic.
And what we're doing here
is we're taking these
input signals and findings,
and we're applying some machine learning
and AI to those in order
to identify whether or not
it looks like a multi-stage attack
that is coming from multiple
different data sources
and also spanning lots
of different events.
We're also looking at and
adding additional signals
that maybe aren't findings.
So we have this concept of weak signals,
where there's something we
know about an IP address
or a domain and it's not
necessarily enough by itself
to generate a finding.
But when we look at that in hindsight
with other information that's now come in,
we can actually apply that to that
and then again raise the severity on that.
And then when we generate these findings,
they come with all of the context
around which MITRE tactics
and techniques that we saw,
as well as all the resources
that were involved,
all the identities that were used,
and a timeline that shows
you when the attack started,
when it ended, what
were all of the actions
that we saw in between,
as well as a human readable explanation
that should allow your incident responder
to very quickly understand
what resources were impacted,
and why we felt that this
needed to generate this finding.
So a couple things about the
extended threat detection.
First of all, there's no
additional cost for this
above and beyond the GuardDuty service
and which those protection plans
that you have turned on.
Again, it completely integrated.
We also add those additional
weak signals to these models
in order for us to
really enrich the output.
And we use a lot of the data
that we have visibility to
about what are we seeing threat actors
in AWS customer accounts doing
in order to train a lot of these models,
and allows us to quickly update these
to identify new and emergent threats.
And when we send out, these
just come as a new finding type.
So the finding types start
with the word attack sequence
and this allows you to consume this,
just as you would your
other finding types, too.
So if you have existing
workload, workflows,
or existing integrations,
these findings will just
go simply to them as well.
So again, we originally
launched with the first two.
At re:Inforce this year, we launched
the compromised clusters for EKS,
which combined CloudTrail, S3 data events,
as well as EKS audit logs
and EKS runtime data.
And then yesterday, during Matt's keynote,
we launched the final two of these,
which is our compromised
compute workloads,
which looks for compromised instances.
So just EC2 instances
that have been compromised
as well as compromised ECS clusters.
So again, for ECS also,
it supports ECS on Fargate
and or ECS on EC2.
One of the other announcements
that we made actually
in the road to re:Invent
just a little over a week ago
was the launch of GuardDuty
Malware Protection
for AWS Backup.
So as I mentioned before,
we already had malware
for EBS and for S3, and what this adds
is the ability for you to seamlessly add
native malware detection
for your AWS backups,
both for EBS as well as S3.
And this can be enabled by checking a box,
no additional software to buy or license,
and no additional compute
required to do this.
It also allows us to automatically scan
new backups as they're created.
And from a cost perspective,
we do incremental scanning
once an additional scan has been made.
And then very importantly, you
can also do on-demand scans
at any time if you wanna re-scan something
with more of the latest virus definitions.
And also, you can have it
so the scans run on restore
to make sure that before you
restore any of your content
that it's been scanned
with the latest malware
definitions as well.
And this can be integrated
into a workflow,
also to prevent an infected backup
from reaching like your
air gap vault for example.
So in this case, we have a backup
that's being backed up from the resources.
As we are performing that scan
or if we're performing incremental scan
to some of that change that data,
we will mark it as infected
if there's malware,
and that can trigger a
results where you will say,
"I don't want this to
get into my air gap vault
to make sure that it
doesn't get committed,"
and that you don't accidentally
back up infected content.
So with that I will show you
what a couple of these look like.
So again, as I mentioned,
this is the EC2
compromised instance group,
the new extended threat detection.
And the first thing you'll notice
is we give you a start and stop time.
So this finding can be
continuously updated.
If we see additional activity,
this same exact attack
sequence will get updated
with a new end time, as
well as all the new data.
So it can be a living finding
if that activity still is continuing.
And we'll tell you
what were the different
types of resources.
So namely in this one,
we had some EC2 instances
that all shared the same instance profile,
and we'll tell you what
instances we saw the activity,
and then the MITRE techniques
and tactics that we saw along the way,
as well as some of the data
around the networks that were involved,
and whether or not there
was malicious processes
or a malware that was identified
in this process as well.
All of this will show you the
MITRE tactics in a nice chart,
so you can see what
were the different types
of attacks that we saw.
And then over on the right,
you can see the full timeline,
starting from the first event that we saw
that we correlated to this attack,
and then all the way down to the end,
including which processes were involved,
if there was a process ID,
if there was runtime data,
just to give you as much
context as to why we felt
that this was likely a
a compromised instance.
So also, I wanted to show you real quick
what the S3 backup looks like.
So if you were to try to
backup a piece of malware,
not only do we show it
in the AWS Backup console
so the backup user can be aware
that there was somehow malware identified,
but it will also generate a
finding on the GuardDuty side
so the security team can also
get visibility into this,
and it will show you information
about what the backup vault was
and also what was the
malware that was fined.
In this case, we used a test EICAR file.
And then lastly, one other launch
that I did want to talk about
that wasn't in our keynote,
but I think is also very cool
and our customers really like.
We had a feature in GuardDuty
for a long time called suppression rules.
And the concept of a suppression rule
was if there was activity
in your environment
that was normal for you
and you would like us to stop telling you
that we're looking at it,
even though it might
trigger one of our rules,
you can create a suppression rule.
The suppression rules previously
were required exact matches though,
so we've added some additional
flexibility to this feature,
where you can now use wild cards.
And that's really useful
in a lot of cases,
where you can use like
either a question mark
or a star or not matches.
So you can say this matches a string
with a wild card or not matches.
So again, just additional flexibility
in creating these rules, so that way,
you can help tune the output
that we're sending you in our findings.
All right, and now with that,
I wanna move on to talk
a little about Inspector.
So inspectors are
vulnerability assessment tool
that is built specifically
for kind of cloud-native applications.
So unlike a traditional like enterprise
vulnerability scanner,
it's not something where
you schedule a scan.
We do continuous scans
and we also support scans
across a lot of all
different cloud constructs.
So with EC2, we also
support containing register.
So if you're pushing
your containers to ECR,
they can be scanned on push,
and make sure that your developers
will even get notice of this as well.
So when there's a vulnerability
identified in the ECR,
we also notify the developer
that this has happened,
so that way, they also can take action.
We can also support scanning of code,
so Lambda function code, as
well as code repositories
that we'll talk about
some more in a minute.
So again, this helps you identify
those software vulnerabilities that exist
across your cloud platform,
as well as unintended network exposure.
So one of the other
things that Inspector does
is it will look at network reachability.
And we use some automated reasoning,
so it supports, for example,
if something's behind a load balancer
or it might not have a public IP,
but we can deduce that it is
actually publicly accessible
if it's behind a load balancer
that's publicly accessible, right?
So helps you understand
which of your resources
are on the public internet.
We use network reachability
as well as other contexts
that we have about things,
like is it actively being
exploited in the wild?
Are we seeing that this,
we know there's an exploit available
and we're actually seeing
it being exploited.
We will use that context to
help prioritize remediation.
One of the other things that we'll use
for prioritization is,
is it in use, right?
So especially important
from a container workload standpoint.
If you have a lot of containers
in a container registry,
odds are you're gonna have
vulnerabilities in some of them.
All of those are things you
probably want to fix eventually,
but the ones you probably want to fix now
are the ones that are actually being run
on your ECS or EKS workload.
So if you're using ECS or EKS,
we will not only show you the containers
in the registry that have vulnerabilities,
we'll show you which ones are being used,
and use that to help prioritize
which vulnerabilities
you should address first.
And then we also have a lot of features
that really help our customers shift left
into the development cycle.
And you know, first of all,
there's an API that you can use
to call in your CI/CD pipelines
that will allow you to
detect the vulnerabilities
in the build process
and then block the bill.
We also have integrations with Kiro
and Q Developer that will allow you
to notify your developers
as they're writing code
if they're about to import
a vulnerable package,
for example.
So we can bring that all
the way to the developer
before the code's even committed,
or if it's in the pipeline
as it's getting built
in the CI/CD pipeline.
The idea being, we want to prioritize
identifying the most impactful
vulnerabilities you have
in your running workloads.
But ideally, if we can
stop a vulnerability
from ever reaching production,
that's obviously the best case.
We use systems manager to
do the continuous scanning
for EC2 instances.
However, if you're not
using systems manager,
we can still scan your
EC2 volumes agently,
agentlessly as well.
And for our code scanning
with Lambda functions
as well as code repos,
we don't just tell you
there's a problem, we'll use Gen AI
to generate a remediation action,
including a patch that you can download
to can just commit that
will fix the vulnerability.
And I'll give you an example
of how some of these work here.
So this is an example of a Lambda function
that has a vulnerability.
In this case, this is a
vulnerability for log injection.
So you can see in this
case, we don't just tell you
which function it is and why
we think this is a problem,
we'll point you to the
line of code specifically
that is causing this vulnerability.
We'll give you an
explanation of why we think
what you've done here is not a good idea,
as well as a recommended fix.
So here's the change you can make,
you can download this
patch, and just commit that,
and it'll fix that vulnerability for you.
Similarly, we support integrating
with third party code
repositories as well.
And in the same idea,
we will scan your code
and your GitHub environments
and scan not just the code,
but also infrastructure is code.
So if you have cloud formation
or Terraform templates,
then we can look at those identified
potential vulnerabilities in those,
for example, in this case, this Terraform
will create an EKS cluster
that will be accessible to the internet.
It's not usually a great idea.
So we'll show you exactly
where in your Terraform
we think you've made this mistake
and give you the recommended
fix, again, with a patch
that you can just simply commit and apply,
and then make the the
vulnerability go away.
With that, I'm gonna hand
it back over to Marshall.
- All right.
All right, so we've talked
about vulnerabilities,
we've talked about threat detection,
now we're gonna go into risk management.
So in this space, we'll
discuss Security Hub.
So this is something that we launched GA
in Matt's keynote yesterday,
Security Hub is being our
unified security solution.
Really, what we were
working backwards from here
is some of these different inputs
that you see on the left side,
like our threats and our vulnerabilities,
we also have things that we didn't cover,
such as Security Hub CSPM.
This is the configuration
of AWS resources,
what might be misconfigured,
not leading to kind of best practices
of how you would configure
different resources
in the most secure way.
There's also other things
like the network exposures
from Inspector, sensitive
data from Amazon Macie
that you can discover in Amazon S3,
as well as access analyzer
that can do things,
like tell you that you've created
a trust policy that share,
that lets somebody outside
of your organization assume a role
or helps with understanding
when policies are not configured
to be least privileged.
So bringing a number of
these different signals
into one place so that
folks can understand,
what is my risk posture across
a number of different things?
So not just, hey, I have a threat here
or I have a vulnerability here,
but let's bring these things together
and understand what resources
are creating the most risk
in our environment that we
should go address first.
So if you think back to some
of those challenges we
went over in the beginning
about, you know, where
do I prioritize my time?
How do I take signals from various tools
and bring them together, you know,
it's ultimately what we want to accomplish
so folks can respond more quickly,
respond across their organization
with the correct prioritization.
So as we introduce Security Hub,
there is a number of different components
that we're helping customers with here.
So kind of once again, unifying
these security operations
across your organization,
with Security Hub,
as you'll see in a minute,
we'll go through in the console.
This is also helping with some
of those deployment capabilities.
So before GuardDuty and
Inspector and Security Hub CSPM
are things that you would
go configure individually
across different regions
across your organization.
Now it was easy to do from a number
of an account standpoint, but
they were still individual
in the nature of deployment.
With Security Hub, we're
introducing the ability
to be able to configure everything
from one central location.
And then that way, we can
have that risk context
brought in together and prioritized,
as well as being able to
streamline the response.
So now that we have all
of this information,
we have different integrations
with different ticketing services,
such as Jira and ServiceNow,
as well as integrations
with Amazon EventBridge
with all these findings,
where you can create
your own response actions if necessary.
Maybe that's tagging
some sort of instance,
maybe that's actually making some sort
of mutating action to
remediate what's going on.
So you'll see some of the key capabilities
that we are introducing in Security Hub.
The first one being these
exposure-based findings.
So we previously had
Security Hub CSPM findings,
we have GuardDuty findings,
Inspector findings,
access analyzer findings.
When we bring these all together
to create a risk-based finding,
that is what we're talking about
when we're talking
about exposure findings.
Another capability that we're
introducing in Security Hub
is in attack path.
So we actually see in a visualization
of the interconnected resources.
And for example, like the
openings between them.
So say for example, you
have an internet gateway
that has certain ports open,
maybe it's just all
ports open to the world.
We can trace that back to our EC2 instance
that's got vulnerabilities,
it's got over permissive instance profiles
associated with it, it has
access to sensitive data and S3,
and you can see visually all
of this different information
and how it's all interconnected.
Another key functionality in Security Hub
is an asset inventory.
One of the things that I've always heard
being a security professional
is you you can't protect
what you don't know exists.
So coming back to that data problem
that I talked a little bit about earlier,
we're introducing an asset
inventory that folks can go
and understand what
exists in an environment,
what exists across your organization,
whether that's five
accounts or 5,000 accounts,
doesn't really matter.
We can see all the different assets,
how many different EC2
instances, IAM roles,
and then what are the findings
associated with each one?
So now you're not working backwards
from a finding and saying,
"Okay, there's this one finding associated
with my EC2 instance.
I wonder what else is associated with it?"
Like what other problems does it have?
You can work backwards
from an actual resource,
you can filter by what resources
have the most different findings,
if it's got the most vulnerabilities,
it's got GuardDuty findings
associated with it,
Security Hub CSPM findings, and so on.
So very powerful from an asset inventory
and working backwards from the resource
instead of working
backwards from a finding,
depending on the different use case
and the investigation scenarios.
And then ultimately, with this correlation
and these different signals
helping with the triage,
now we're getting you closer to the answer
that you needed to go say,
"Here's what I need to go remediate,
here's who I need to go contact,
who has access to these resources,"
instead of you putting all these pieces
of the puzzle together and
then going to a response.
We're putting those pieces
of the puzzle for you.
That way, you can get to
your decisions faster,
get to your alerting faster.
And we're also helping that
through those integrations
with things like ServiceNow and Jira.
All right, so with that said,
I'm gonna show you what this looks like.
All right.
So another thing that we didn't touch on
in the slides yet is cost estimation.
So obviously, anything that
you do in the AWS console
from, you know, enabling
a service a lot of times
has a cost associated with it.
One thing we've heard from customers is,
"Hey, I need to know how
much this is going to cost
before I turn it on.
I might need to get approvals
from my finance department."
Now with all of these different services,
everything we've talked
about to this point,
they all have different free trials.
Those free trials might be 15 days
for things like Security
Lake and Inspector,
they might be 30 days
for things like GuardDuty
and Security Hub CSPM.
All of those different
services have usage spaces.
So you can see exactly what
that service would cost you
during that free trial.
And you can have an exact estimate.
With the cost estimator
that we're introducing in Security Hub,
this is an ability to
create an estimate based
on what we can see from cost
and cost explorer in your environment.
So based on historical patterns,
which does obviously not
exactly a projection out
to the future, but based
on historical patterns,
this is what it would cost for
you to turn on this service.
And when I talk about
turning on this service,
there we go.
One of the other things
that we've introduced here
is simplified pricing.
So before, if you turn on GuardDuty,
it had a line item associated with it,
different protection
plans associated with it.
If you had Security Hub CSPM turned on,
it has line items and it became, you know,
kind of complex pretty quickly, right?
There's a a number of different line items
that you need to decipher
on how much is this costing me in total.
With this simplified pricing,
we're essentially bundling
what we see customers
normally use together.
So we have this showing in
a couple of different ways.
So in a couple of different packages.
So Security Hub essential capabilities,
so this is Security Hub CSPM,
Inspector scanning for things like CIS
and ECR, and Lambda and EC2,
also GuardDuty foundational data sources,
and malware protection for EC2.
One of the the different components here
is to be able to create these
rich exposure -based findings.
Getting that data into Security Hub
to be able to create those findings.
This is kind of the
baseline amount of services
that is what's needed to do that.
And with that, we've also gone
to an easier way to estimate this.
So it's now per resource-based pricing
instead of usage-based pricing.
So for example, usage-based
pricing in the past,
folks would need to understand,
well, what are the usual
trends in my environment?
And obviously with the
cloud, you can scale up,
you can scale down.
It looks like Ryan's got
somewhere to go after this.
But yeah, you could scale
up, you can scale down.
You don't really know
what exactly that might be
over a month's time.
With the usage-based
pricing, we can take it,
we can understand like an
average of EC2 instances
across the time and come
up with a better estimate.
And then one thing to note
that you'll see on here
is when you do this
different bundled pricing,
we also give a more
competitive pricing rate
associated with using all
of these things together.
You know, you're opting in to
a number of different features
and if you do that, right,
there's different cost
advantages to doing that.
One thing to note is you can
use these still, individually,
but if you want to take advantage
of the easier simplified
pricing, you know,
we definitely encourage you
to take advantage of this.
But you can do this either way.
And then another thing here
is if there's the different essentials,
you can turn on just the essentials.
You can turn on the essentials
plus threat analytics,
as well as additional capabilities,
which today exists with
Inspector Lambda code scanning
and kind of adding these
things on, you know,
piecemeal based on what you
want out of your environment.
So let's go to what this
looks like in the console.
So Security Hub, we've kind of,
this is the new Security Hub page.
So if you haven't had
a chance to see this,
definitely come give this a look.
One of the things that we've introduced
and one thing I failed to
mention earlier, sorry,
is this was in public preview
at re:Inforce this year,
and then obviously yesterday,
we did the GA announcement.
There are some new things in here.
If you looked at this in
public preview before,
you're gonna see some new things,
such as the trends in this.
So for example, you can
see in a day over day
or week over week, and then you can see
across these different finding types.
So for example, the
threats from GuardDuty,
the exposures from Security Hub,
you can see your amount of resources,
total amount of findings.
And if you scroll down, we
have some different charts
and things that you can filter by.
You know, say for example
you only wanna see
your critical level threats
and you can kind of see what
this looks like over time.
Another key widget that's
on this summary page
is security coverage.
So talking to security
professionals a lot,
one of the questions is,
"Hey, I wanna make sure
that I have this coverage everywhere.
You know, it's part of our
standard operating procedures.
I need to tell an auditor that
we have these capabilities
across our environment, and I need to know
that that's what we have."
So now, we're giving that
information to make sure
that folks have an easy way to see
that you have coverage
everywhere versus, you know,
going out and looking at
the different consoles
and understanding what exists there.
And then, like I said earlier,
we are actually making
this a little bit easier
for folks to understand what exists.
So the account coverage, we can see this,
that, hey, all of these different accounts
in our demo environment,
we have 100% on everything.
But you could see what accounts
have vulnerability management,
what accounts have the threat analytics,
which ones have sensitive
data discovery configured
or posture management.
And then you can configure these
based on these different data types.
So Security Hub, the essentials,
based on like what we were
seeing from that pricing page,
the threat analytics for GuardDuty,
and this is once again policies
that you can set at an OU level.
You can set across an whole organization.
And from here, Security Hub will make sure
that you have all of these
capabilities turned on,
or you know, whether
you have five accounts,
whether you have 5,000
accounts based on that policy.
And then obviously,
switching it up if you need,
you know, maybe different coverage per OU
or something, right?
And then moving on here to,
what does these exposure
findings look like?
So we talked a little bit about this.
Let's scroll down here and
look at just the first one.
We can see that the
potential finding title
is potential resource hijacking,
EC2 instance with an open security group
has software vulnerabilities.
This groups by the different EC2 instances
that have this risk.
If I go ahead and click on one of these,
and I'm actually gonna expand the view,
so hopefully you all can see it better.
So if we look at this,
we get like a, you know,
basic summary at the top.
This instance has
accessible within the VPC
and has low priority vulnerabilities,
exposing this instance
to resource hijacking.
One of the things that
folks usually ask about is,
hey, I've got vulnerabilities,
they're critical.
They're a remote code
execution vulnerability,
but we don't actually,
this instance doesn't have
access to the internet.
So you know, somebody
couldn't exploit that.
So those are the types of things
that we're helping customers
bring to the surface here.
Maybe you do have some critical
level of vulnerability,
but it's remote code injection
and it's not exposed to the internet.
So that's maybe not as severe as,
hey, you've got this
medium level severity,
but this instance has every port,
every IP open to the world.
So, you know, it's kind
of just a matter of time.
That's something we should go prioritize
and focus our time on.
If we look at this one though,
we can see the attack
path here, little small,
but we can see everything that's involved.
So like the EC2 instance, what's the VPC?
The different IAM role, the IAM
policies associated with it.
So we can see, you know,
not only does this thing
have vulnerabilities,
but it's got an IAM policy
that's named administrator access.
So most likely, an administrator.
We can see the contributing traits.
So if we think of contributing traits,
this is where the underlying
detection sources,
so the things like threats.
In this case, misconfiguration
with the security group,
vulnerabilities associated
with that EC2 instance.
We can see all the different traits there.
Let me go up.
Once again, we can see the traits
or we can see the different
resources involved with this.
So there's, you know, an EC2
instance, a security group,
the subnet, and an IAM role.
This is specifically the things
that need to go be
remediated all in one spot
from multiple different sources.
All right.
Cool.
So with that, let's go back here.
So why build Security Hub in this way?
Why customers would want
to use Security Hub, right?
We're trying to unify these
different data sources,
these different detection mechanisms.
They're rich data from
things like GuardDuty,
from things like Inspector.
Putting these things together,
so folks can get closer to the end state
of I know the data sitting in front of me,
I have a decision to make,
or it's already built on
my playbook hopefully,
and I can now more easily
make those decisions.
This ultimately will help
save you time, right?
You're not needing to
do that triage yourself,
not needing to do this
risk analysis yourself,
getting closer to that.
And then the other things
like simplified pricing
and simplified deployment,
making it even easier
to enable these services
to operationalize these services,
get them approved at your organizations,
making it overall easier
to get these detection
and response outcomes out
of AWS native services.
So I'm gonna take a moment to talk
about Security Hub plus OCSF.
If you're not too familiar with OCSF,
this is the open cybersecurity
schema framework.
So it's a data standardization
for different log
and finding data.
This is an open source
solution that got open sourced
in, I believe it was 2002 or 2022,
and it actually joined the
Linux Foundation in 2024.
There's over a thousand
participating organizations,
AWS being a major contributor to this,
but a number of different vendors
that I'm sure you all
are very familiar with.
But all of these security findings,
these exposure-based findings,
the findings that we're ingesting
from the underlying detection services,
these are all in OCSF format.
So when you're potentially integrating
with a response solution
or some analytics solution,
you have standardized findings to get you
into analytics a little bit easier.
So like, whether it's a vulnerability,
whether it's a threat,
the different fields
are gonna be the same, the
different data sources,
or it's already understood.
And, you know, ultimately,
working with a bunch
of the different vendors
that you might be using,
using the same standard format
can help streamline that.
So like I touched on one simplified bill,
we wanted to make the
billing process much easier.
Predictable pricing, cost
estimations, a single invoice,
you're not doing this across services,
and just simplifying,
you know, oftentimes,
for security professionals,
like we don't wanna
handle the billing stuff.
We want to focus on the security stuff.
And so we want to get you to focus
on the security stuff faster
and less focus on the billing.
Go through this real quick.
The number of services
that we've talked about,
we've mainly focused on the GuardDuty,
Inspector, and Security Hub.
There's other pieces
of this puzzle, right?
Macie for sensitive data discovery.
You can feed your data
into Amazon Security Lake
or the newly launched at
Matt's keynote yesterday,
the CloudWatch unified store.
This also in integrates
with investigation functionality
in Amazon Detective,
as well as AWS Security Incident Response,
which we'll touch on
real quickly in a second.
So AWS Security Incident
Response, if you're not aware,
this is a service that is in the console.
It combines a couple different things.
It helps customers
prepare, respond to faster,
and more effectively respond
to these different security events.
It combines different triaging technology
behind the scenes to bring in
a bunch of findings together.
And as well as human expertise
from our customer incident response team
that Ryan touched on earlier.
And ultimately gives
customers direct access
to a security professional 24/7
that will look at the
output of that triaging
and help customers respond to
and recover from any
sort of security issue
that they might be having
in their environment.
One thing that we launched
earlier this week too
is the ability to that
this is actually part
of enterprise support.
So if you're an enterprise
support customer,
you can turn this on
with no additional cost
to get these added benefits.
So something you should look into.
It takes pretty minimal
configuration to get up and going.
If you're not an enterprise
support customer,
there is metered pricing and a free tier
that you can take advantage
of for this as well.
Another big launch in the
Security Incident Response service
was an ag agentic
AI-powered investigation.
So this is bringing an agent
experience into this console.
So right now, there's a triaging system
that whittles down different
findings to say, like,
"Here's the one that you
should prioritize based
on some different factors associated
with an individual
customer's environment."
But then there's investigation steps.
What other IPs did this
EC2 instance interact with?
What other CloudTrail data was associated
with this IAM role during this time,
maybe the seven days before.
Like there's other
questions that you'd want
to answer based on this
finding information.
That agent does a lot of that work based
on some pre-training and the expertise
that the customer incident response team
has built up over the years.
So that when the human, on the AWS side,
the security professional
and your team get together,
there's already a number of the steps
that used to be a human manually doing,
they're already completed.
So now we can have the discussion faster,
we can get to the end stage faster.
What are the decisions we
need to make for response?
What do we need to go remediate?
A couple other things,
HITRUST certification,
some ticketing with ServiceNow
and Jira direct integrations.
And then we also made
it to where customers
could not only deploy this
across their organization,
maybe they only needed it associated
with one OU or a specific account,
or they needed a combination of both.
And so we made it easier
for customers to do that
from a picking and choosing
where they want to deploy.
So with that said, I wanna
say thank you, everybody,
for coming to this.